welcome to the news are the death toll
from the outbreak of coronavirus of
Italy has surged by 919 in a single day
that is the highest daily increase
recorded anywhere this the peak in Italy
or is the worst yet to come is yet to
come of course this is the deadliest day
you need to listen to the beginning of
the outbreak 919 people died in the last
24 hours the Civil Protection said it is
a massive increase after last week when
the losses attested around between 600
and 750 daily so the total toll now
reached 9,000 134 the confirmed cases
are around 6,000 today we're bringing
the total number of positive people over
86,000 scientists and experts warned
every day that these figures are not a
hundred percent accurate especially for
what concerns there positive cases
because in the hottest eight regions
there could be as many as 10 times more
people affected this is what the head of
the Civil Protection keeps saying so the
Italian Health Service is under strain
and it's not possible to test more
people as we speak
the Italian president Sergio mozzarella
is starting to address the country in a
nationwide message it's it's just the
second time in three weeks he will speak
to the population about the emergency
give us an idea if you can of how the
health system is coping we're hearing
around the world different countries are
saying we don't want to become Italy
what is the situation in Italy now the
situation is very different from region
to region let's say that here in the
northern regions especially in Lombardy
the the hospitals are full the intensive
care units are completely overwhelmed
so from Lombardi patients are brought to
other regions or to
other states like Germany for example so
the situation is that we don't have
enough people to test everyone we don't
have the instruments to test all the
people that would need to be tested so
the contention is probably much more
broad than than we know of course the it
was not easy that's what the government
says it was not easy to understand what
what was happening at the beginning but
when Italy understood locked down
everything quite quickly not only not
all the countries have done so that's
why we will see what what will happen
here and and other countries do thank
you veteran Cisco Jamba Tony live from
Milan